in california
thanks for doing this with us ashton um
maybe i mean everybody i think that
listens to this knows you knows who you
are like
in general but maybe can you just in one
minute or in two minutes in your own
words like explain like what did you do
the past 43 years two minutes for 43
years yeah no problem i grew up with a
twin brother and
from from a very young age i realized
that it wasn't all about me
um we grew up in a
middle-class family in the middle of the
united states my parent my dad was a
factory worker my mom was a school
teacher um
my my brother had a heart transplant
when we were 12 years old and i also had
an older sister um
my parents split up uh my mom moved out
into the country when i was about
about 12 13. and so i lived on a farm
for most of my high school years i went
to college for biochemical engineering i
dropped out after one year uh moved to
new york with a hundred dollars and my
boy scout duffel bag became a model
traveled around the world uh modeling
for a year um realized that that wasn't
the the the career for me found a
bathing manager started acting within a
couple months uh flew to los angeles my
first day in los angeles i got a job on
that 70s show started working as an
actor how did that work i mean i mean
like how is that happening like this is
like the one i think cutoff point where
everybody else like fails you go to la
and the minute you go there you seem to
have an acting job
uh yeah i
i mean i i was an actor in school um did
every single high school play junior
high school play that i could do i was a
member of the national lesbian society
went and competed in my state acting
competitions in iowa uh when i got to
new york and i was modeling there was a
period of time where i wasn't working a
lot and i did a student film for nyu
to understand what it was like to
perform in front of a camera uh realized
it wasn't a whole lot different than the
stage but but there were some
differences and then i i auditioned
for that 70s show in new york and put
myself on tape and sent it out and
didn't get the job and then or went to
los angeles actually to audition for
another uh show for mbc and auditioned
and they told me i wasn't funny uh and
then my manager said hey
i want you to go meet the casting
director for that other thing that you
read for and when it went across town
read for it then went red for the
producers and then got the job oh okay
okay so i got a job on the 70s show
realized that uh in an ensemble cast
there was a lot of time where you were
just sitting around waiting for your
turn to rehearse or perform i started a
production company when i was about 21
years old and built up a team we created
a show called punks and produced the
butterfly effect and produced a show
called beauty and the geek and true
beauty and a bunch of other reality
shows and and a couple scripted shows
somewhere in there i started seeing
buffering speeds just getting faster and
faster online uh and i thought all of
this content is going to be digital
content at some point and we should
start producing content for a digital
audience and we started exploring
companies that
could help us quantify the distribution
and and accelerate the distribution of
content
uh
met a couple people from the valley that
were looking at that space
and through that network started meeting
other interesting startup companies that
were doing things that previous to the
sort of explosion of the iphone
weren't really available all of a sudden
there was gps in your pocket and
internet in your pocket and all these
other things music in your pocket that
were were never in your pocket before
and there was an explosion of companies
that were coming out that i thought were
interesting
i tried to convince my board and my
producing partner that we should pivot
our production company uh to creating
content on behalf of those companies uh
and invest in the companies don't take
compensation for the production of
content but just invest in those
companies and build a portfolio of value
that way they didn't think that was a
great idea so i started investing on my
own and and writing my own checks into
early stage startup and
and then started to build a portfolio of
companies
at the time there was really one other
person in los angeles in the
entertainment ecosystem that was
spending a lot of time in the valley
that i would go up and take meetings
with various founders and they would say
hey
what do you know about this guy and it
happened to be guy osiri who was a
friend of mine
and so he said to me we're the only two
people doing this let's partner so we
went and brought in a third partner a
guy named ron berkel and we all put our
capital in and started our first
investment fund which was a grade we
built that up to about 100 million
dollars in assets um and and then uh
raised some outside capital from friends
of ours and people that we knew that
that filled in blind spots that we had
whether it was an enterprise
sas tech whether it was you know other
folks that had a better understanding of
the underlying technical platforms that
we were looking at
and so basically brought on lps that we
looked at as an advisory board
and then uh we split from our third
partner ron and built our own fund
called sound ventures and we're on i
think fawn three of sound ventures at
this point
and along the way built a bunch of other
stuff so okay okay that that's a very
impressive wrap up
like starting starting with your media
adventures and which one would you say
was your most important um
production or
a movie series that were you involved in
that that's most impactful for your
career
oh that's actually really tricky that i
mean probably the most impactful is
that 70s show it's not very often that
the very first you know
major job that you take becomes a
running success
and fundamentally it's usually the first
thing where people believe in you that
gives you a platform
to be someone that people believe in so
so i would say that 70s show was
probably the most
the cornerstone
after that i think
i think punk was really important for my
career the mtv show yeah because it it
i made it i built it from the ground up
with my partner
there there were a couple key moments in
my life
one was moving to new york where
everyone said this is a bad idea you
shouldn't do this but i had an instinct
that i should and i did it um and it
turned out to be a good decision the
second was when i made punk because all
of my representation and everyone said
yeah you shouldn't do this this is why
are you going to go do a reality show
and i went with my instinct and we built
it and it turned out to be successful
but it also taught me that i could build
things
that it wasn't just about acting but
that i could put together a team lead a
team and build something and make
something that's original
and that's an important thing for people
to know and understand in their lives
that they can build things they can make
things that never existed before
and
for me to learn that at a young age was
really powerful
was it just coincidence or was it a plan
behind you always like playing internet
people i mean you had the the guy on two
and a half men was basically an internet
genius and you had steve jobs uh who you
portrayed well
the character on tuneup men so when i
took that
role
uh originally it wasn't that character
so uh i met with chuck lorre and
we had conceived a character that i was
going to play
um
and then he became so fascinated with my
life and what i was doing as a venture
capitalist that he then changed the
character to map more to my life as a
venture capitalist
there was nothing coincidental about
that that was him making a decision that
he wanted to model the character
after me
and then steve jobs was an intentional
choice a i wanted to learn more about
him
and be um
i really admire
him and and who he is
and when i received the script and
started investigating
some of the things that were in there i
i just i i wanted to honor uh someone
that i really looked up to so that was
that was a choice
maybe you can say a few words on how the
whole like
moving image
industry has changed i mean we all talk
about streaming wars and the streaming
platforms and it feels like from the
early days
the tv series and the mtv shows to today
it's a whole different industry is is
that true
no
i don't think so i i think fundamentally
it's the same
thing um you know you start with uh
an idea you turn it into a plan
you you know get the supplies or the
people together to build it and then you
assemble it
the thing that's the only thing that's
really changed i think is the
distribution outlets
and the ideas
i think that there there are some
fundamentals in
the kind of content that works and i
think the reason for that is there
there's so many other it's a war for
eyeballs right but all media is just a
war for eyebrows whether it's or ears
right so if you think of it from that
perspective
there's just so many more outlets where
people can consume content uh with their
eyeballs so it's a time on site time on
channel equation
that is being run across all of these
variable platforms
i think that what people are realizing
is
you can have a ton of content
that has
short
attention span
but that is high value or you can have
a
a long-form piece of content but it has
to have
high net value across and so that's why
you're seeing all the studios moving
towards these massive tentpole films
that are
more and more
optimized for the bang
that get people to catalyze around them
because it's an economics game that is
all built around the eyeball war
okay i mean but it seems like if you're
an actor what matters also is you have
to have a huge social media following
and that shapes careers now it used to
be all about the talent it seemed and
now it's like about the talent plus the
social reach
well the social reach game is uh is a
function of the you know promotional
capabilities of the talent right you
know it used to be you get actors that
are in people magazine and us weekly
and can get on a talk show
and that those were the actors that you
would hire because they could help you
promote and sell
your movie without having to spend more
money right yeah and they created these
bifurcated deals where you would get a
portion of your compensation for
actually performing in the film and then
the other portion of your compensation
came for promoting the film
and when talk shows when getting on
david letterman or jay leno or oprah was
a big deal
you needed to get actors that could get
on to those platforms and and or get
promotion in us weekly or people
magazine or one of those things and
those were the actors that you would
hire and you bifurcate the deal and
ensure that they would go on x number of
talk shows or international talk shows
for that matter
now because
the performers have gone direct to
consumer with their promotional
capabilities
what folks look at is what is their
social reach and then what is the
concentration of click-through rate of
that social reach and and can they reach
their audience to give us free ad
dollars against our media
what's the most important social
platform for you these days what are you
most active on
for me the most important social
platform is community
it's it's a direct text messaging
platform it's only available in the us
and canada right now you invest
yeah
but
because i invested isn't the reason why
it's the most important to me
it's most important because
i think that most social platforms are
made with the assumption that people are
one-dimensional
that
you have an audience of fans and all of
the fans are fans of you for one reason
therefore
you have reached to your fans where you
can say something and all of your fans
can see it
but then they always run into a signal
to noise ratio issue where
at some point you have fans i have
people that are fans of
me as a venture capitalist i have people
that are fans of punk i have people that
are fans of the ranch or two and f men
or people that are fans of my non-profit
work with thorne
and and they're all different kinds of
people and and you don't speak to all of
those people the same way and you don't
tell all those people the same things
like people that are just fans of my
philanthropic work
they don't care about my acting work and
they don't care about my venture capital
work people that are just fans of of my
work in technology
may not care about my philanthropic work
so community allows me to message people
specifically
almost like subreddits
based on their their interest in me
what are they interested in about me
and then further more i can narrow that
down and talk to people on their level
so i'm not going to talk to high school
student the way that i would talk to
a
my mom so i can narrow it down and say
okay for this is a message for people
who are
you know 16 to 20 years old
that are interested in my acting and i
can just post a message to those folks
or i can say okay this is a group of
people that are just parents
and maybe they want to understand you
know or maybe i had an insight about
parenting that i want to share i can
just send it to parents i don't need to
send it to everyone and community
respects my ability to do that how many
followers do you have on this platform
um i think i have like 135 000 people uh
on the platform but the interesting
thing is whereas i have millions of
followers on these other platforms
the click-through rates on community
and the open rates are exponentially
higher than the open rate so if i post a
tweet maybe three to six percent of my
audience will actually see what i post
when i post something on community
90 open rates uh and like a 65
click-through rate on every single thing
i put up so it's it it is it's it's not
as vast yet but the ability to influence
or the ability to share is much greater
because the click-through rates are so
much higher and the open rates are so
much higher is the long-term idea of
this platform to be a tool for
people that already have like a name
established through other channels sort
of like you that then use this platform
to to continue their career on this
platform or is it a platform where
everybody can become a star
i think it's a platform where
everyone can connect to
their audience the way they want to
i almost see it as like a personal crm
okay um
it could be a personal crm for
individuals or it could be a tool for
companies
where
maybe you're a nike and you're launching
a shoe and you're launching it
specifically at one demographic right
you know it could even be for
i mean i i've been spending some time on
clubhouse
and when you have a thousand people 5
000 people in a room you can only bring
x number of people up on stage and so my
new tactic is to go on clubhouse
put out my community number and then
i build a filter on community where all
of those folks go into one specific club
or community on community and then they
can ask questions into my community
channel and it uses nlp to sub stack the
questions so i can see if 20 people all
have the same question and then hit that
question as opposed to having to
constantly invite people up on stage how
old is the how old is community as the
company
it's like a year old okay so it's early
stage very early stage yeah it's super
early so so
it's my new it's my new favorite okay
and uh say a few words on clubhouse and
we just mentioned it clubhouse is that
gonna be here to stay is that the new is
that a new hot thing
and it's gonna last
yeah there's no question it's gonna last
i i mean they they crack the code and
and because they
kept the platform really really
lightweight
they got a
really
highly dense
collective of people that have common
interest
to join
and now the interest verticals are
building one by one by one by one
when i look at these things i i look for
cult-like behavior where you have the
cult of
whatever interest graph it is um and
there's so many cults inside of
clubhouse like colts in the good sense
where
you have people that are all interested
in the same thing
coalescing consistently and if you look
at time on on platform
it's
through the roof and their growth is
through the roof and yeah
i i think it's hard to stop that kind of
inertia and momentum
do you spend a lot of time there
yourself i mean are you there like once
a week or twice a week or even more
um
i'm i'm there once a week for sure
i would be there more but i have a
four-year-old and a six-year-old and
they wake up awfully early in the
morning and
once they're in their you know
quarantined pod school i'm working
and once they get home i'm with them and
by the time they go to bed i'm exhausted
so
uh most of the time i just ghost inside
a clubhouse and i put it in in my ears
when i'm laying in bed
so i don't really participate is i don't
really speak in the rooms i just kind of
ghost around and listen to what people
are saying to try to understand
you know people have divergent
perspectives to mine but you don't you
don't go into those rooms with your with
your real account right you have your
like a fake account so nobody's gonna
call you on stage right
no i go into rooms i just refuse to go
on say i go into rooms that are my
account i just refuse to go on stage uh
okay okay okay but but i try not to go
into rooms where
i have a common interest
because i generally understand the
perspective of of the people in those
rooms i try to go into rooms where
i don't have a common interest or where
the
demographics of the room are are
extraordinarily different to me so that
i can understand the way that other
people are thinking okay okay you you
recently almost broke a german twitter
because you posted about a german
politician or you you i mean it got into
a conversation with a german politician
there the leader of the social uh
democratic party zaskia esken
in germany um how did that come
well
i i don't know that i almost broke
twitter
in germany
it's pretty resilient these days um
i'm a privacy advocate i have been
my whole life
and and i advocate for privacy because
i've been in the public eye for long
enough to recognize the value of it i've
had my social security number and bank
accounts put on public threads and had
to rearrange things and go and breathe
i've had you know life-threatening
situations that are a result of lack of
privacy
i've had my accounts hacked
everything else
so i am a staunch privacy advocate i'm
also a huge
advocate for children
and believe that children deserve
privacy as well
so thorn that the baseline of my
nonprofit is we build software to fight
the sexual exploitation of children
and to defend children and
the problem that we have in the world
around
child sexual abuse material is massive
and the internet is the backbone of it
it's an issue that's growing
exponentially and it's an issue that
we're building software to fight back
against and a lot of companies use
software intelligence and ai
to detect
known child sexual abuse material and
remove it from the internet
so that it doesn't exist on the internet
it's illegal to have on servers it's
illegal to share with people
and
so there was a piece of interim
legislation
that was being proposed that would be a
continuation of the existing law to be
able to detect and remove child sexual
abuse material and that interim law
basically the law was expiring and there
was a proposal for an interim law
to allow companies to continue to look
for known child sexual abuse material
the privacy advocates on the other side
were saying we don't want companies
looking at our information looking at
the things that people are posting
these companies don't have a right to
look at these things
and we were advocating for
we agree with you but
they should be able to look for child
sexual abuse material
so there was an interim law that was on
the table that didn't happen in time
and every month that goes by
that there isn't a new law that allows
companies to look for this material
there's evidence
in the cases
for these kids
that is being lost because the companies
cannot look for that material
and all i was saying when i was reaching
out to those legislators is
privacy isn't something that is absolute
it
and for this particular case it would be
really valuable for us as a society to
have the evidence and and
you know they continue to battle about
it which is exactly what i knew was
going to happen
didn't want to have happen and was
reaching out to these folks to say
i you i mean
sasha esken
went to mit
you know like she understands how the
internet works how did you find her i
mean how did you who pointed you to her
we have a policy team uh on
on our side because regulation really
matters so
you know you don't want to build
software into the headwinds of
regulation
and we work with
a bunch of major tech companies to find
this material and we're helping you know
rebuild the infrastructure
that allows us uh when material is
reported and comes in
to
have ai look at it instead of have human
beings look at it like
to basically catalog it create hashes so
that we can go okay this is a known
piece of child sexual abuse material we
don't want it existing anywhere else on
the internet let's hash it and go take
it down in in these other places
that's what we do so so we have a policy
team that that helps us understand where
the regulation is happening that is
going to impede the work and so they got
flagged and it got sent to me and then
we got active and we're still active and
and here's the thing
these politicians understand this
and so these kids lives
are now in their hands because they're
choosing
to not
put down an interim law that just allows
companies to continue to look for this
material and take it down it is more
nuanced than that but we've had several
cases where
we finally found these kids and and the
kids photo was you know the
the the face on the mother's facebook
profile
and we could have found it but we can't
because the law is keeping us from doing
that and keeping companies from being
able to do that i think that that's
silly i don't want to live in that world
okay okay enough i mean i get it i get
it um before we get back to like your
social responsibility i want to ask you
on venture investing like
from the outside it looks like airbnb
must have been your most successful
venture investment in in terms of money
is that is that a fair fair um research
um i think so yeah i'm i'm not sure
i
i i
i i i in one sense i'm i'm like the
worst venture capitalist in the world
because they
i actually don't look at
the capital i the capital returns are
are it's like the contrails of being an
investor right like
you so when you're the pilot you're sort
of looking out to make sure you're not
hitting a mountain
you're not looking back
at the contrails that your plane is
leaving behind you so
i i i hope so
and and i would assume so um because the
ipo went really well
what i see is the
potential for airbnb to continue to have
extraordinary impact in people's lives
bringing the world together and making
people recognize how similar we are as
opposed to consistently looking at how
different we are to me that's the power
of the platform from that respect i
think we've we've been pretty successful
but can continue to be more successful i
mean among all your we could we could
talk for hours about all your
investments you made tons of investments
those past years any other investments
that stand out to you that were like
different than others from a like
economic standpoint or from a personal
standpoint
so we we have a a matrix that we invest
through the first being is the founder
somebody that you would want to go work
for because we believe that as investors
that we work for
the founders and and you've got to want
to be employed by them to some to some
extent you know we've just met some
extraordinary people along the way
it's whether it's been
you know daniel eck and spotify
or
uh ryan peterson at flexport or
enrique
from brex or
julian from we fox or yeah julian the
german guy
yeah yeah german guy my wife was
shooting a film
in berlin
and and i i had my venture capital hat
on as i always do and and met with him
while she was shooting one day and was
like okay
i would want to come work for you and i
like what you're building and so
unfortunately i wasn't in berlin long
enough because i probably would have
found a lot more companies but
you know
ultimately
i mean there's an extra yesterday we
were on on on a call with the founders
of a company called ethic
which is which is basically
building the the ability to
optimize your esg goals
in your passive equity portfolios which
is extraordinary you know you can sort
of tune up or tune down whatever your
passions or interests are so if it's
climate if it's if if you care about
human rights if you care about
you know inclusion and diversity
you can tune up and down your passive
equity portfolio to meet the standards
that you want to meet and still get the
returns that you want to get and like
that's a platform that you just look at
you're like
wow that's that's gonna
that's gonna change the world
we just invested in a company that is
in the autism space where they're
trying to get people access to aba
therapy uh for their kids at a young age
and and helping them get access to
um the spectrum test to determine
whether or not your kids need aba
therapy the the innovation of
extraordinarily generous and
mission-driven companies
just keeps coming
and and and we just keep leaning into it
and it's it's
it couldn't be more fun
[Music]
coming
in again
problems
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how do people approach you i mean how
did julian find you i mean he's a guy in
berlin building a startup how did he
reach out to you how do people in
general reach out to you
i think i reached out to him we were in
budapest
um
and
i was meeting with the founder of
ustream which was one of my early
investments when i was looking at media
at the media space specifically
and then met the blah blah car guys and
then
met uh like
with speedvest which is like one of the
number one fintech uh investment groups
in in europe and then they
said hey you should check out this
company we fox and then i reached out to
julian i think that's that's how it
happened okay okay and i mean before
that it seemed like your german
investment a track record is not making
you happy i mean there's a couple german
things you tried out i think already a
couple years ago ayman and
go butler and these things and i mean
you're also like people know that here
but they didn't make you happy in the
end
yeah well i wouldn't say that they
didn't make me happy in the end
you know
amen didn't work but it
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that it didn't
was didn't make me happy i i met some
extraordinary people
made some great friends phoenix and
yeah felix is great and
he's come to los angeles we've spent
time together and i've been to berlin we
spent time together and
you know just because an idea doesn't
work doesn't mean it wasn't successful
and you know should we have pivoted it
or tried to pivot it yeah
earlier yeah but we saw signals that it
was working so we leaned into it and it
just didn't gain mass appeal
you know there's a company called gidesy
that i invested in around the same time
there was an experiences platform that's
not a lot different than what airbnb is
doing with experiences today but that
was 10 years ago um and it and
they just couldn't build the platform
density around experiences
to to really get the engine going
and that's okay like it wasn't a bad
idea and they were smart founders and
good people
it just didn't get consumer traction
fast enough to gain that momentum and
inertia that you need to be a successful
startup
you know soundcloud uh there are a lot
of extraordinary artists that have come
up and been build off the soundcloud and
soundcloud
may still become
an extraordinarily profitable company we
don't know
but i i became really good friends with
alex and and and and that is worth it
and i'm talking to him about his new
company dance that he's building
so
life is a journey right and if you're
only focused on financial returns
that would be a pretty dull existence
but if but if you recognize that the
value can become can be the experience
you might see better financial returns
because you'll recognize the mistakes
you made you'll recognize
what you did wrong you'll learn and
sometimes knowledge is more valuable
than money will ever be how much do you
invest usually
what's our average check size yeah
uh in our newest fund our average track
size is between three and five million
okay so that's a serious a fun then
yeah
and series a b c i mean i i don't think
the alphabet means anything anymore
i think there's there's there's
basically like we haven't built it yet
that's that's that's one stage um
there's we have a product market fit
and there's
we're scaling
like those are the three things and so
usually we like to see a product market
fit okay okay and who i mean who do you
invest with i mean i know you have your
own fund but like can you explain a
little bit about like the landscape
there in in in hollywood silicon valley
i mean there's so many like investors
now and also celebrities athletes
how do you look at this
so
we have
several funds that over the years like
we share our deals with and they share
their deals with us and because every
fund that we work with has a
differentiated value at
and we can say they're extraordinary at
enterprise s they're extraordinary in
fintech they're extraordinary in
building an engineering team they are
extraordinary in whatever it is whatever
aspect they're extraordinary and
we try when we look at a deal
if if we're there first to go find the
best co-investor for the company
that's within our network and so we have
a couple funds on the east coast that we
work with pretty pretty close we have a
couple funds in the valley that we work
with really quite closely
like like we have a presence who for
instance do you work with closely so we
work really closely with thrive capital
uh in new york we work really closely
with general catalyst in boston
we do quite a few deals with the box
group and we've done some stuff with
union square and there that's
the east coast
we were close with andreessen horowitz
uh on
deals we were close with uh sequoia on
deals um so that's the youtube names
yeah we did it it really just depends
like we just want to bring the best
investors to the table that are going to
help the companies the most like
we always say to founders like we're not
going to make your company successful
you're going to be successful we
wouldn't even be talking to you if we
didn't think you're going to be
successful we just think we can help you
get there faster we we can bring
something to you that you can't hire
what do you usually what do other
investors or founders look for when they
especially go to sound ventures so your
friend are they coming to you because
there's ashton kutcher there or what are
they looking for
we have a growth team that
really focuses on like funnel
optimization on on
any kind of
you know on on on optimizing growth
channels for companies so
that can be relevant to consumer
companies it could be relevant to sas
companies
and so we really try to lean into that
we have some pretty unparalleled
marketing expertise
my partner guy who siri you know he's
he's managed madonna for since he was 18
years old and
uh and manages you too and
has done a ton of other extraordinary
things his
i think is is a
brander like somebody who's really great
at branding i i think he's one of the
best
we have
totally differentiated you know business
development
jobs our rolodex is fully differentiated
from
you know most other
investors and then
just from being in the room with some of
the best product minds in the world i
think we're really great at prawn
product
and and you know we've done things that
people wouldn't expect like we helped
airbnb find their international partner
because of our careers
our other careers
you know guy travels around the world
and and
he knows people all around the world i
fl i end up in germany while my wife is
shooting a film and and meet people that
other people just aren't going to know
and so
i think that brings a lot to the table
as well
but at the core i think we're just
committed to working hard
and we believe that any problem a
company has there's a solution for it
and we're willing to roll up our sieves
and work
to help those founders get to where they
go or where they want to go
and if they need a dentist or a doctor
or whatever you know we can do that too
is there anybody in in venture capital
investing that influenced you that they
like sort of taught you the game i mean
you like model an actor and then from
the midwest you don't know the venture
capital game like that i mean who taught
you all this
i still don't know it
i think the most influential person has
been ron conway
i met him i went to like tech crunch 50
before it was tech crunch disrupt before
it was techcrunch 100 and met ron conway
and he took me under my wing under his
wing and
you know
basically showed me the landscape i
think paul graham was really influential
and and jessica livingston the y
combinator i just kept asking them like
when you choose companies to come into y
combinator what are you looking for that
helped
create a an understanding of
what what to look for in a founder
ted schlein at
kleiner perkins was super influential
and and
just asked him questions about cyber
security and so we can understand that
field
mark benioff has been an unbelievable
mentor in in our understanding of sas
dan rosensweig
has been
extraordinarily valuable in
understanding edtech
mark cuban has been
really influential uh for us
and and then our partners like you know
our peers
you know josh kushner at thrive like he
and i will sit down and just grind on a
deal for an hour and i get to see how
he's thinking about it he gets to see
how i'm thinking about it and then
you become better because you just are
trying to surround yourself with as many
world-class people as you can and
then you just read a lot of books
is josh kushner the josh christian that
also the co-founder of the oscar um uh
insurance company
yeah
okay the brother of the the
the husband to uh uh trump right
yeah jerry's brother yeah exactly
exactly okay
can you give me your opinion on a couple
of like the hardest trends right now
what do you think on nft
so we're we're really active on nfts i
mean
and we've seen this coming for years you
know we invested in in bitcoin
when it was
like 25 bucks a coin or something like
that just personally we we invest in
crypto through our fund
and we've just been believers in crypto
for a really long time i i met vitalik
before he ever launched ether
and
you know he explained to me smart
contracts and
what seemed obvious
is
that
the the first application
of
crypto was going to be one-to-one value
storage
which bitcoin was optimized for somewhat
i mean when lightning network comes then
it'll actually be optimized but that
seemed to be the first obvious
application which is why we're also
interested in ripple and xrp and got to
know you know chris larson and brad so
so we've been really
and
by the way they've been
awesome to us throughout the years just
explaining what they're doing why
they're doing how they're doing and
giving us an education in the space so
i look at it like this the the the
protocol layer being the smart contract
layer
is there
and it took
the value storage layer being btc to to
start to gain maturity to validate
that blockchain was gonna be a thing
now that blockchain is a thing
we can start to do
really really fun interesting stuff with
it and
it looks like the protocol layer for
that is going to be ether it could be
flow and what dapper is doing
um
but
assuming ether does what they say
they're going to do
which is
launch their next version that
allows for
transactions to happen
and thus reducing the price of gas
i think it could very much be the
backbone of this nft ecosystem
so so the base layer is built what needs
to be built on top of that for the nft
ecosystem to really take off
obviously we have to have minting
technology and and you have to get to
low code no code on minting so that
people can mint objects
at a regular basis you've got to build
out all the permissioning that is
necessary in in order to allow the sort
of long-term capital flows and then
you've got to build out the marketplaces
that will exist on top of that so i
think we're there at
a pure play infrastructure level and it
seems like there's momentum around will
for people to put in the work necessary
to build these next layers so that an
app ecosystem can exist on top of this
yeah we're going to see a lot of busts
were you like were you surprised when
you saw this auction recently at
christie's where there's people
artwork i mean basically it's a it's a
jpeg whatever we'll call it um i mean
the you know the people the artist um
yeah was so sold for 60 million or
something was it was shocking was it
just oh no that's just normal well
you
you have to consider underlying
incentives
so some people see it and they go wait
somebody just paid 65 million dollars
for a jpeg
and other people say
wait what is the
underlying
value to the holistic ecosystem
of paying 65 million dollars for a jpeg
i'm not saying that this is the case
but i i would look at it and go all
right
who acquired it
how much of the underlying token do they
hold
what value does acquiring it at that
rate
actually bring to the underlying token
and so what kind of a multiple on the
underlying token did they get
so whoever paid 65 million my guess is
they made more than 65 million off of
paying 65 million for that piece of art
so that's the way i would look at it
follow the money
okay okay so so you're saying they they
also investors in either
um the the this flow network or the the
currency so they're making this money
back somehow
i'm not saying that yeah i'm saying i'm
asking the question yeah yeah i mean
it's it's okay it's an obvious question
yeah it's good
but but but here's the thing these
things these things do have underlying
value there's there's no question that
there's underlying value like i i look
at
nft
and
this is going to be a giant ecosystem
there's no question and we are actively
investing in the space like and and
we are not sitting back going
there's nothing that there's something
happening here
we just don't know
it's it's it's hard to know
who the absolute winners are going to be
in this space yet
there are going to be some giant busts
in the space there's not a question
about that in the same way that we
talked about
two promising companies out of berlin
that we invested in early on
that
didn't get to the finish line there's
going to be busts in the space
but there are going to be winners
without a doubt and
you know it
we have no problem assigning value to
physical objects
and there are a ton of virtual objects
that have value
that haven't had ownership rights
historically
that are about to have ownership rights
and this underlying technology anytime
that we have a transaction
with two parties that don't know each
other or don't have underlying trust
with one another
but they're transacting something that
is virtual
that can have retained value
it's an opportunity for the nft market
to go to work and it's going to go to
work
[Music]
maybe maybe uh
i mean not that you're also a very like
active climate investor climate is i
think a topic next to
child security that really
is this is you know moving you um
can you say a few words on that and also
like how does that
fit with with um you know crypto and all
these mining issues
well so you have massive energy
consumption issues relative to crypto
that will be solved over time i think
there's no doubt that it's that that's
going to be solved over time and it most
certainly is something that we are
paying attention to it's most certainly
something that we're looking at
and right now the blockchain solutions
that exist aren't efficient enough but
what does technology do it creates
efficiency and over time
there's going to be efficiency created i
mean we've been promised lightning
network for how long
that would create extraordinary
efficiency and there there are some
platforms that are more efficient than
others that are built and
being deployed so that's good news
on the climate change front
we are
extraordinarily active in that space
the way we invest out of sound is um we
look at cultural themes
find a cultural theme find a cultural
theme that's starting to get resonance
inside of the entertainment community
that that we know that the influencers
are there
that it's going to be a thing and then
we invest into that space
we're
we're so convinced that climate change
is a thing that we've built an entirely
isolated vehicle that's just focused on
that particular issue
and and we're actively looking for
solutions in that space are you bullish
on that i mean i mean it's probably the
the biggest issue for our generation um
and are you like bullish and positive
you're going to solve this problem
uh yeah
there's no doubt i mean
you just said it right it's the biggest
issue for our generation it's a thing we
care about the most
consumer choices are going to be made
based on sustainability of companies in
the same way that ethic is building
passive equity portfolios that you can
tune up or tune down
the impact of you know co2 emissions
that a company has and you can decide
that those companies aren't going to
exist inside of your investment
portfolio consumers are just going to
start making decisions based on that
like if the product that you're
consuming doesn't have a closed-loop
system or recyclable system
people are just going to shun it because
the the closed-loop system or recyclable
system
option is going to exist
there's no doubt about it but do you
think billions of people are going to
understand this i mean we're talking
about like yes you know this and then
silicon valley knows this but like
there's billions of people out there all
over the world will they understand this
would they especially in time you just
said it it's the biggest issue for our
generation our generation is going to
have more buying power in the next
five years than any other generation
and so they're going to make those
decisions i watch my kids
at four and six
that know what upcycling is nobody
taught me what upcycling is when i was
in school
you know they know what recycling is
they know they understand
this and care about this and know that
our planet is fragile we didn't even
when we were talking about recycling
when i was a kid
i didn't know the planet was as fragile
i didn't i wasn't aware of that like i
wasn't aware of the sort of long-term
effects
these kids have the benefit of their
parents
being educated
on this issue
there's there's no doubt
that that there are going to be markets
that are built and and bran massive
brands that are going to be built
that are brands that just say
we can do it for the same price
and our and ours doesn't kill the planet
okay
last question
i think it was a great podcast why are
your own podcasts so rarely why do why
do i don't listen to your podcast with
you more why can't i i can only find you
on two or three other podcasts
i'm busy working
that's funny
about all the i just told you about all
the things i'm working on you're like
why don't you have more time to talk
about what you're working on
i'm working all right
did spotify not reach out to you yet for
a podcast i mean they have bruce
springsteen on the podcast
we'll get there when we get there
all right okay that's how they're saying
thank you ashton it was a pleasure all
right thank you very much thank you for
doing this thank you take care
[Music]
software either before the next
firmware
startup software einkoff zeiss moon
video conferencing software is marketing
software payment software
software
information
reviews is the place to go
[Music]
these are podcasts
from podstars
by om air